المترجم: Fatima Zahra El Hafa
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(تصفيق)
اسمي إسماعيل حيميش.
سأحاول اختصار قصتي.
كما سأحاول أن أستخلص منها بعض العبر،
التي أعانتني في حياتي.
وفكرتي هي أن تصل إلى الناس.
اسمي إسماعيل حيميش، كما سبق وذكرت.
كان عمري حينها 16 سنة،
وكنت أقطن مع والديّ،
مثل جميع المراهقين.
كنا نقطن في مدينة السعيدية.
وبعد انتقالي للسلك الثانوي،
ذهبت لأقطن مع عمتي في مدينة فاس،
لأدرس هناك.
كان الأمر صعبًا في البداية،
بسبب بعدي عن والديّ وأسرتي،
كما كان عليّ الاندماج في وسط جديد
والتأقلم مع عادات أصحابه.
كان ذلك صعبًا في البداية.
كنت أشتاق لوالديّ وكان عامل البعد عائقًا.
باشرت دراستي وبدأت بعض العلامات
على تدهور صحتي في الظهور.
كان يُغمى عليّ،
ولم تعد لدي شهية للأكل،
وكنت أصاب بنزيف أنفي وصداع رأسي.
كانت هذه الأعراض تتفاقم مع مرور الوقت.
لدرجة أنني كنت أفقد وعيي
وأصاب بالصرع،
كان البعض ينسب ذلك إلى المسّ،
والبعض الآخر يقول أنني بدأت أجنّ.
بالطبع، إذا أُصبت بأعراض كهذه،
فستحاول معرفة السبب.
بعد ثلاثة أشهر من الفحوصات،
أُصبت بورم على مستوى العقد اللمفاوية،
فأجريت خزعة عند طبيبي المعالج.
لم أكن أستطيع النوم،
ووصلت لدرجة ضرب رأسي بالحائط
من شدة الألم.
بعد إجرائي للخزعة،
أخذت الفحوصات للطبيب وحدي.
قمت بكل شيء لوحدي
خلال تلك الثلاثة أشهر،
وأنا بعمر 16 سنة ونصف.
بعد ذهابي للطبيب،
أخبرني أن عليّ انتظار نتائج الفحص
الذي قمت به،
والتي تتأخر لأنها ستُدرس في فرنسا.
لكن الألم ازداد،
خصوصًا بعد استئصال تلك العينة
من الورم لاختبارها.
كان اليوم جمعة،
وكنت قد توصلت لتوّي بنتائج الفحص،
لم أكن أستطيع الانتظار
حتى يوم الاثنين لمعرفة ما بي.
ذهبت لسيدة تعمل في المختبر
وطلبت منها قراءة وتفسير النتائج لي.
أخذتها وقرأتها وأعادتها إليّ،
ورفضت أن تخبرني عن محتواها.
تذكرت مجموعة على الفايسبوك
للممرضين والأطباء،
صوّرت النتائج ونشرتها هناك،
كذبت عليهم قائلًا:
"أرجوكم ساعدوا هذا الولد
على فهم محتوى هذه الوثيقة،
فطبيبه مسافر، وهو مستعجل."
فأجابوني بأن هذا الولد مصاب بسرطان نادر
لم يسمعوا به من قبل.
صُدمت وانهرت بالبكاء،
لم أستطع تقبل الأمر.
السرطان كلمة مرعبة تُوحي بهواجس
كالموت وكل ما هو سيىء.
كيف سأبلغ هذا الخبر لوالديّ
الذين يقطنان بعيدًا عني مسافة 350 كيلومتر؟
وكيف سأزف هذا الخبر لعمتي؟
ابن أخيك أتى لإتمام دراسته،
فإذا به يصاب بالسرطان!
ظللت أفكر وأبكي.
وهذا أمر طبيعي، فأنا إنسان.
بعدها اتصلت بأبي وقلت له:
"أبي، أريد أن أخبرك بأمر ما.
هل أنت مشغول حاليًا؟"
وكان كذلك، فعاود الاتصال بي،
وأخبرته بكل شيء.
انهار أبي بالبكاء، مستحضرًا صورة والدته
وأخيه اللذان فقدهما بسبب السرطان.
لم يُصدّق.
فطلبت منه أن يخبر والدتي، فوالدتي حنونة
ولم أكن أقوى على إخبارها.
المهم، مرّت هذه المرحلة بسلام.
بدأت جلسات العلاج الكيماوي،
وتعرفت على ممرضتي
التي فسرت لي أّنّي مصاب بسرطان نادر،
يُصيب الأشخاص الذين يعيشون
على الساحل البحري، ونسبتهم قليلة،
حيث يتواجدون فقط في المغرب
والجزائر وتونس.
كما أخبرتني أننا سنُباشر العلاج الكيماوي
والعلاج الإشعاعي،
أما استئصال الورم، فهو أمر صعب جدًّا.
فأخبرتها أنني موافق، فقد تقبلت الأمر.
وكان كذلك، فتعرفت على العلاج الكيماوي
والعلاج بالأشعة.
كانت الحصة الأولى صعبة جدًّا،
بقيت ممدّدًا لتسع ساعات،
توخز الإبر في جسمي
وحولي أناس فقدوا شعرهم،
الكل ممدد، الكل يحتضر، الكل يصرخ.
فذُهلت.
كانت تلك أول مرة
أخوض فيها تجربة مماثلة.
عند عودتي للمنزل،
بدأت الأعراض الجانبية في الظهور:
القيء وفقدان الوزن وتساقط الشعر...
تعرفت على بعض الأصدقاء
في مركز الأورام: عمر ونورة ومريم.
تعرفت عليهم بعد التحاقهم بي.
كنت وحيدًا في البداية،
اتّخدت من وجودهم حافزًا لي،
فقد كانوا يقربونني في السن.
حاولت الاندماج وأخذنا نحفّز
بعضنا البعض.
كنّا نلتقي في قاعة الانتظار
ونضحك مع بعضنا البعض.
تغيّرت نظرتي بعض الشيء.
فقدنا نورة بعد ذلك، فقد تُوفيت.
بقيت أنا ومريم وعمر.
بعدها ذهب عمر لإجراء عملية
في فرنسا لزرع النخاع الشوكي.
فتُوفي عمر.
لم يبقَ إلا أنا و[مريم].
وكان كل واحد منا يترقب
موت الآخر بخوف.
أنا أترقب موتها وهي تترقب موتي.
جاء آخرون: موسى ومهدي، وتُوفوا كذلك.
كنت ألاحظ هذه الانهيارات،
وكانت والدتي قد أتت لتكون بجانبي.
كنت قد تركَت والدي
وأخي الصغير في السعيدية.
كانت والدتي تذهب معي للحصص
وتعاني وفي كل مرة تلتقي بالنسوة هناك،
اللواتي كنّ يخبرنها بقصص أحبائهم
الذين ماتوا بسبب السرطان.
كنت أرى والدتي تنهار في كل مرة بالبكاء.
وهي تعلم أن مصيري إما الحياة أو الموت.
كنت أرى ذلك وأنهار.
وقلت في نفسي: "يجب عليّ
التغلب على واقعي بحافز نفسي."
طلبت من والدتي أن تعود
إلى جانب أخي وأبي لرعايتهما.
وأقنعتها أنني قادر على العناية بنفسي،
كما أن عمتي بجانبي.
اقتنعَت بصعوبة وعادت أدراجها.
بعد ذلك عثرت على صفحة
لفتاة على الفيسبوك، تدعى دلال.
كانت دلال مصابة بسرطان العظام،
وكانت تشارك مسيرتها على الفايسبوك،
أملًا في إعطاء عبرة ودرس
في التعايش مع السرطان.
تحليت بشجاعتها وبقيت على تواصل معها
وظلت تنصحني،
أُعجبت بمبادرتها وقررت الاحتذاء بها.
فحفزتني على ذلك.
ما زالت كلماتها عالقة بذهني حين قالت لي:
"إسماعيل، أنشئ صفحة على الفايسبوك.
وواصل مسيرتي إذا ما حدث وتوفيت".
وفعلًا، توفيت دلال.
فظللت أفكر كيف أن دلال
كانت تمنح الشجاعة للآخرين،
إذن يجب علي أن أستثمر ما استفدته منها
وأعلّمه للآخرين.
فأنشأت صفحة على الفيسبوك،
وكتبت قصتي هناك، فأعجب بها الناس.
وبدأوا ينظرون لي بشكل مختلف.
مع العلم أنني واصلت مسيرة علاجي وحيدًا،
كنت أذهب لحصص العلاج الكيماوي،
وأتتبع نتائج فحوصاتي،
وأقوم بالعلاج الإشعاعي.
كثيرًا ما كان يغمى عليّ،
وكان الآخرون يسألونني عن والديّ.
عندما يسقط المطر كنت أعاني مع المواصلات.
كل هذه المعاناة مررت بها،
وكانت حافزًا لي.
كنت أقول في نفسي:
"أنا وحيد، أنا أبي وأمي. هما بعيدان عني.
سواء مت أو بقيت على قيد الحياة،
المهم هو أن أصل."
كانت كل عقبة أمر بها تمثل حافزًا لي.
كانت عائلتي في فاس لا تزورني.
فكنت أحزن وأقول لم لا يزورني أحد
مثل باقي المرضى؟
أنا أعاني وحيدًا.
ثم أستدرك وأقول لا يهم، فالله بجانبي.
وجدت الدعم في الناس.
كنت أقرأ الشجاعة في عيون الآخرين
حين يأتونني ويقولون:
"أنت إنسان متفائل يا إسماعيل،
رغم صغر سنك،
استطعت التغلب على مرضك
وما تعيشه بسببه."
هذا الكلام كان حافزًا لي،
فنسيت مرضي وألمي وكل شيء.
لدرجة أنني لم أستعن قط بمسكنات الألم،
رغم أنني كنت أشعر بألم شديد.
وكنت كلما اشتدَّ بي الألم،
أحمل حقيبتي وأسافر.
ربما يستغرب بعضكم
كيف لمريض مثلي أن يسافر،
لكن ذلك كان حافزًا لي.
كان مرادي هو تخطّي تلك العقبة
ونسيان آلامي.
ما سبب ذلك؟
لقد اكتشفت أنك عندما تبقى وحيدًا
ومنعزلًا في قوقعتك وكئيبًا
تتساءل عن سبب عدم زيارة الآخرين لك
وعدم اهتمامهم بك وسقوط شعرك،
يجب عليك أن تحاول نسيان مرضك
وتحاول الخروج من تلك الشخصية المنهارة
والكئيبة إلى أخرى متفائلة.
فأصبحت أخرج ولا أكثرت لنظرات الناس
بسبب شعري المتساقط، وجسدي الهزيل،
وخوفهم من أن أصيبهم بالعدوى،
رغم كون السرطان لا ينتقل بالعدوى.
لم أعد أكثرت لأيّ من ذلك!
تعرضت لكل ما ذكرته،
لكنني حاولت تجاوزه.
كنت أحمل حقيبتي وأسافر.
كنت أدون كل حصة علاج كيماوي أمرّ بها
على صفحتي، وكان الناس يُعجبون بذلك.
كانوا يأتون إلي مثلًا ويقولون لي:
"طفلي لا يريد الذهاب لحصص الكيماوي،
هلّا أتيت معي للمنزل وأقنعته بذلك؟"
وفعلًا، كنت أذهب وأُتحدث إليه
وأروي له قصتي، كيف كنت وما مررت به،
وأريه صوري، فينظر إلي ويبكي
وينظر إلي بعينين ملؤهما الإصرار
يتخذ مني صاحبهما قدوة.
فالناس يثقون في من عايش نفس التجربة
التي يمرون بها.
كما يقول المثل المغربي: "لا يحسّ بشدّة
ألم العصا إلّا من ضُرب بها."
فكنت أُسقط ذلك على تجربتي،
وبدأت أرتاد مراكز الأورام
للأطفال المصابين بالسرطان
في جميع مدن المغرب: وجدة، الرباط...
حتى أنني ربطت علاقات معهم.
وفي كل مرة
يرفض فيها أحدهم العلاج الكيماوي،
أذهب إليه وأضحك معه وأريه الصور.
وأؤكد لكم أن العديد منهم
أصبح يواظب على علاجه
وشفي الكثير منهم.
وقد بثّ فيّ هذا الحماس.
وكانت جرعات الحماس تلك
أنجع من مسكن الألم.
لدرجة أنني توقفت عن تناول هذا الأخير.
ولو أنني كنت أكذب على طبيبتي
حين تسألني عما إذا تناولت دوائي،
فأجيب بالإيجاب.
وقد كنت أحس بأنني في أتمّ الصحة،
عكس الحال الذي كنت عليه سابقًا.
عندها عرفت أن الجانب النفسي
والمودة والحب
وأن التصريح بما تحمله قلوبنا،
أي حاجز، سواء المرض أو عقبات
في الدراسة أو عقوق الأبناء،
أو أي شيء صعب،
يمكن للشخص مواجهته وتخطيه،
وسيصل لا محالة.
لا تلتفت للآخرين أو للماضي.
لقد وهبك الله نعمة الحياة،
فعليك بالاجتهاد والمثابرة.
لا تنتظر أن يساندك الآخرون.
أقنعت نفسي وكنت أحدثها بهذا كله.
فلم يكن أبواي بجانبي،
وكان علي تحمل مسؤولية نفسي لوحدي.
أصبحت أرى في نفسي تلك الصورة
التي يراها في الآخرون:
مصدر محفز على التغيير.
فأحس بسعادة غامرة.
وأصبحت أواظب أكثر على حصص العلاج.
انتقلت الخلايا السرطانية
لأعضاء أخرى في جسمي كالمعدة.
ورغم ذلك لم أفقد الأمل في الشفاء.
كانت طبيبتي تحاول إقناعي
أن ذلك مستحيل،
وأنه لم يعد بإمكاني
مواصلة العلاج الكيماوي،
لكنني لم أكثرت لا لكلامها ولا للعواقب.
(تصفيق)
شكرًا.
لقد أعجزت وأبهرت الأطباء،
كانت طبيبتي تقول لي:
''لقد كنت أنا والطاقم الطبي
نؤمن بأن حالتك ميؤوس منها،
لكنك أبهرتنا بتغلبك على المرض
في كل مرة دون الحاجة للدواء!"
وكنت كلما أخبرتها أنني لم أنتاول دوائي،
تعاتبني.
لكنني كنت أشعر أنني في حالة جيدة،
وكذلك كانت نتائج فحوصاتي.
وأقول لها: "العلاج يا طبيبتي
مرتبط بالحالة العقلية والنفسية،
لا بالدواء. فهذا الأخير
لا يعدو كونه مجرد سبب."
فكل شيء مرتبط بتغييرك لذاتك
وتفكيرك بنفسك.
لماذا مات فلان الذي كان مريضًا؟
لأنه كان منغلقًا على نفسه،
لا يربط علاقات مع الآخرين،
ولا يبحث عن منبع للتفاؤل.
هذا هو ما أريد وأحاول تبليغه للآخرين.
البعض يرى أن الأمر مرتبط بالشهرة،
لكنني لا أعتبره كذلك.
بل هو حب الآخرين ورسالتي في الحياة.
فسواء متُّ أو بقيت حيًّا،
ستبقى بصمتي خالدة.
حين يأتيني الآخرون ويقولون لي:
"نحن أيضًا كنا مرضى
وكنا نستمد الصبر منك."
كان هذا يعطيني حافزًا نفسيًّا.
ما أريد إيصاله للآخرين هو ثابر،
وحاول أن تصل وستصل.
لا تكثرت لا لكلام الناس
ولا للعقبات ولا لأي شيء.
فالله وضعك في الدنيا وحيدًا،
كابد وثابر وصل، كما وصلت أنا.
فقد تحسنت حالتي
حسب نتائج فحوصاتي الأخيرة.
سأصل لمبتغاي.
وبالنسبة لصفحة الفايسبوك خاصتي،
فقد حصلت على جائزة أحسن صفحة بالمغرب
للسنة الماضية من Maroc Web Awards،
بمعدل 40 ألف صوت.
لم أكثرت للفوز بقدر
ما اهتممت بذلك العدد من الأصوات.
كيف استطاع 40 ألف شخص الاقتناع برسالة
هذا الشخص والتصويت له لتشجيعه؟
الإجابة تحمل في طياتها رسالتي.
فالآخرون لن يسخروا منك
ومن شعرك المتساقط،
بل سيدعمونك نفسيًّا ومعنويًّا،
وهذا أحسن بكثير من الدواء
وكل ما هو ماديّ.
هذه هي رسالتي.
(تصفيق)
شكرًا.
شكرًا جزيلًا لكم.
(تصفيق)